[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a moment that is going to change
this nation this is a moment that forges
character
[Music]
9/11 was nothing compared to this and
people come in I get intubated they die
the cycle repeats
we are New York tough we are tough you
have to be tough this place makes you
tough
we're going to overcome this and America
will be the grater for it
tine square normally a manic mass of
people now almost totally devoid of them
this is a city many of us feel we know
the one that never sleeps and now look
at it once again it is ground zero
[Music]
[Applause]
this is going to be weeks and weeks and
weeks this is going to be a long day and
it's going to be a hard day and it's
going to be an ugly day and it's going
to be a sad day this is a rescue mission
that you're on the mission is to save
lives Elmhurst Hospital in Queens the
site of an apocalyptic surge in one of
New York's poorest neighborhoods bleak
long lines of the sick waiting to be
tested a virus already out of control
and a country the most powerful on earth
overwhelmed America went from just 15
cases of corona virus in the last week
of February to having the world's
highest number of deaths now tens of
thousands of people
we saw that disaster unfold on the front
line
[Music]
it was a journey that started in New
Rochelle a suburb of New York where a
synagogue was at the center of an
ominous outbreak
[Music]
the National Guard deployed a
containment zone established
but it didn't stop spring breakers weeks
later flooding Florida's beaches
now it's the horrifying numbers of the
hungry that fill our screens millions
out of work and in search of a meal the
specter of a 21st century Great
Depression
[Music]
there's no magic bullet there's no magic
vaccine or therapy
it's just behaviors each of our behavior
is translating into something that
changes the course of this viral
pandemic in the next several days to a
week or so we're gonna continue to see
things go up the next week is going to
be our Pearl Harbor moment it's going to
be our 9/11 moment it's going to be the
hardest moment for many Americans in
their entire life how quick and stark it
was being Congress sight of a field
hospital in Central Park a tourist
hotspot now called the hot zone
at the start hospitals couldn't find
enough space for the sick the city still
can't find it for the dead
it's helped
biblical
I kid you not
[Music]
the rest three years he respond
we're on shift with captain AJ Briones
in Yonkers he's a paramedic working
seven days a week and it's nonstop
everybody calls us the frontline but
we're really we're the last one so money
somebody who's really sick you have to
get there as quick as you can but you
also want to be safe thing that we talk
about is we're not on one there is no
not one two three larry temple
AJ's team is getting three times the
usual number of call-outs because of
coronavirus these days they're the first
and sometimes the only emergency
responders that go into people's homes
struggling with breathing we got a real
sense of just how much pressure how much
work these paramedics are having to do
often on their own they're at risk
there's every chance they - to get
exposed to covert lighting back in New
York City we go inside Brooklyn's
biggest Hospital an ER that's become a
war zone where there's a constant crush
of covert 19 casualties
[Music]
so we're now in the critical care area
of the emergency department everyone
that's in here today is here due to
breathing problems almost uniformly
often coded we sing such a large
increase on a day-to-day basis on a
number of patients who are presenting in
critical condition requiring really all
the resources that we have to provide in
order to help them doctor eight and
Dikmen says there are normally seventeen
beds in this room at Maimonides Medical
Center today there are 32 patients and
the numbers are rising rapidly every
hour this pandemic demands more people
more space and more staff willing to
confront a lot more danger so we have
opened up new ICUs new intensive care
units we've opened up the new medical
units in order to accommodate for this
increased demand of patients who are
coming in so ill
everywhere in the hospital is now
effectively an intensive care unit and
they're seeing every type of person in
this ethnically diverse borough
this is an intense demanding and
desperate atmosphere in here the
patient's keep coming and it's not just
the elderly it's the young too and
they're always struggling it's a
daunting new frontier for medics even
for the most experienced we're obviously
single large number of critically ill
patients yeah I've seen some of the
papers I've ever seen in my whole career
not only do they have coronavirus but
they also have their diabetes is out of
control particularly hard and we're
learning how to do it it's a very sharp
learning curve and an often brutal
experience for those with existing
health conditions really the main effect
that we're seeing is it's is a
significant effect on impairing the
lungs ability to provide the oxygen that
the body needs and then it spreads it
affects the heart it affects the kidney
ultimately unfortunately often Sable
times taking the ultimate toll
throughout this crisis there has been a
shortage of personal protective
equipment
Maimonides was well prepared but across
the city supplies are on a tightrope
[Applause]
concerned about the days ahead I think
we're in for a significant period of
seeing a lot of very very ill patients
and this is gonna put a strain on the
system we want to make sure that we have
enough supplies including PPE for the
staff including ventilators high flow
oxygen devices at this time we do have
sufficient supplies but that's something
that we're monitoring very very closely
their work starts on the streets triage
tents at the front for their living
refrigerator trucks at the back to carry
the dead
but here is where brave doctors and
nurses worked every minute risking their
lives so others can avoid that fate
[Music]
America imposed travel restrictions on
China pretty quickly it has now tested
more people for covert 19 than any other
country to
[Music]
but that aggressive screening didn't
happen early enough regulatory hurdles
technical flaws and lapses in leadership
meant it spread undetected for weeks
President Trump meanwhile has gone from
skepticism to optimism to sounding the
alarm one person coming in from China
and we have it under control it's gonna
be just fine
is this just like flu because people die
from the flu when you have 15 people and
the 15 within a couple of days is going
to be down to close to zero that's a
pretty good job we've done it's going to
disappear one day it will disappear this
is a pandemic I felt it was a pandemic
long before it was called a pandemic but
this is going to be a very painful very
very painful two weeks we took good care
of every place we didn't we didn't miss
a trick but could he have seen what was
coming Eric Lipton and a team of
journalists at the New York Times
claimed health officials concluded that
it was time to move to social distancing
back in the third week of February but
that recommendation wasn't made directly
to mr. Trump then there was a consensus
that was reached among the medical
advisors that it was the time had come
to to flip the switch and to go to
what's called mitigation which means
social distancing closing schools
closing businesses causing intentionally
causing economic harm to United States
was just something that Trump really did
not want to do but the time had come by
the third week in February to make that
difficult choice because that you were
gonna save potentially a million lives
if you did that and and Trump was
unwilling to do that until March 16th
and that was basically a week or two
late for places like New York Michigan
Massachusetts New Jersey Connecticut
Louisiana places where there are more
deaths than there needed to be if the
United States had switched the
mitigation sooner
[Music]
[Music]
yes world
[Music]
small-group yes if you just give me a
call to let me know when you're coming
because we are a little busy and I want
to make sure somebody is here to sit
down and speak with you properly Jerrod
Neufeld funeral home was at the heart of
managing the mounting death toll and it
still is demand is just unfortunately a
lot of debts all at the same time so
we're trying to manage services for all
the families in a proper way whatever
they want to do so and it's just a lot
of families well at the same time so
we're trying to get fit in schedules
trying to keep track of who's you know
which day which families got to go and
go from there
people are fortunately passing away in
big numbers and because they live in
this area and I'm the only funeral home
left in this area they're coming to me
so so I'm trying to accommodate them the
best I can and every day yes yes I mean
we left the office last night and I
think we had about 12 services or so
scheduled and shortly after I left the
office within two hours I had three more
services and then this morning as soon
as we came in we put on three or four
more services so that's what's happening
and and it's only twelve o'clock Robert
Lee o gay has just lost his grandmother
Anna her family suddenly robbed of the
chance to grieve together
my grandmother died alone those tough my
grandma
she died alone we didn't even get to say
bye des and I understand that's part of
the death process but she was zero she
was in the hospital she was feet away we
couldn't even see how we couldn't touch
to talk to her we couldn't even give her
like that boost of morale to say hey you
know you're gonna come out of this we
need you to come out of it it's late
there was nothing what would you say to
those people who don't think coronavirus
is a serious threat if you don't think
that it's a serious threat Here I am I
lost my grandmother and I'm in the mess
of less than a week Roberts family had
just celebrated her 80th birthday they
call her the glue now they too are
infected she was exposed to the virus
they also became it's also the virus and
half of our family member right now are
in quarantine because they tested
positive
with collective mourning forbidden and
traditional rituals removed death is
marked by a drive through the Crematory
is really aren't letting anybody in the
cemeteries eliminated for the most part
two people stayed in their cars and just
watching the burial from the gravesite
Joe negotiates at the gates
[Music]
carrying the candles for the families
that can't sometimes when it's so brief
it almost leaves them still feeling in
hollow like you know what just happens
they don't have enough time to process
it
it it's heartbreaking it's really sad
[Music]
in these alien times there is no group
goodbye
it's a little after dawn and we witness
just how great and grim the scale of the
problem is
on this truck bodies of the dead
this is Hart island where coronavirus
victims are among those being
temporarily buried in mass graves
unclaimed by a family member or unable
to afford a private funeral there are
normally 25 caskets a week placed here
now it's nearly that many every day
in the centre of the city there are
makeshift morgues everywhere some places
are running out of body bags
the authorities acknowledge the death
toll is likely higher than the official
figures but no one knows just how much
this team at Long Island Jewish Medical
Center work in a morgue processing and
examining those killed by coronavirus I
really admire our colleagues on the
front lines that are dealing with the
patients that are coming in with the
Cova Dean their triaging them they're
managing and they're treating them but I
think people also need to realize that
there's another front to this war and
that's the front with the dead it's not
just the sheer volume of cases that's
challenging they're also trying to find
a new way of communicating with
relatives it's always working with hard
working with the families at this point
in time but even more so now when when
you know they're not able to see their
loved ones in their last moments I've
had to improvise to try and support the
bereaved offering them a chance to see
those they've lost using video calls
this time that was the FaceTime so I did
first let her see me explain you know
what she's going to see asking her if
it's okay that she's you know are you
able to see this you know because we
couldn't keep it the way we normally do
as far as you know having sheets and
there was a body bag and you're seeing
her face so that was difficult it must
be very surreal and distressing for a
family to have to look at their loved
one on FaceTime I'm not going to lie
they're great
it was tough
it's you know it's if we could do at
least one small thing to make this hard
time for them a little bit easier that's
what we're gonna do and no matter how
crazy our day is and how much work we
have to get done we're gonna do our best
for our families that we're dealing with
their their families
[Music]
carrying out lots of post-mortems will
be crucial to understanding the virus
and ultimately saving lives
Lisa normally deals with all the
administrative issues but there are so
many bodies she now has to help move
them to the three of us were outside and
we just collapsed on like a crate and we
were just done you know we're exhausted
we're physically exhausted were mentally
exhausting
[Music]
they expanded their morgue others
haven't been able to
it is a structure that simply wasn't
built for this level of strength
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
across America what we can now see is
that certain groups are
disproportionately affected
in Louisiana 70% of those who have died
are African Americans that they
represents only 32% of the population in
the Lower Ninth Ward destroyed by
Hurricane Katrina they're bracing for
another disaster Anita's mother Mary has
fluid on her lungs but she took her out
of hospital fearful she might also get
coronavirus so make sure she don't die
from me because another thing you know
your people dying from it and they alone
they are alone we want to go out like
that
you can't have a proper barrier for
being honest in it so we just say we'll
stay here with mine and tell all this
fair solder all right it's very risky
for her and for us just as well because
it's a monster
we can't even see it but we know is it's
here so basically that's why we've been
doing keep the house bleach clean
everything so we could have more time
with my mind she's 75 years old how
scared are you for your mama I'm scared
to death like she come out and catch a
little fresh air but I I let her catch a
little fresh air cuz she's still half a
year she can't stand up there and be out
there and be out come catch a little
fresh air and then we go back in black
people are more likely to suffer
comorbidities - diseases like obesity
and diabetes they also work in riskier
front-facing service jobs those factors
have played a huge role in this path
damnit it's the perfect storm of
problems here poverty poor access to
healthcare and poor health when you
speak to people they'll also tell you
that this is a place of big families who
live close together and love to hug that
has been a hard thing to shake
the famous Mardi Gras is to city
officials pressed ahead with it in late
February a heaving mass of people on the
streets
two months later New Orleans had the
highest death rate in America but that
was long before a national emergency was
declared
this is known after an Easter Sunday
service in Baton Rouge
[Music]
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal and are endowed
with with rights from their creator with
certain unalienable rights among these
are life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and this freedom that I have
my governor it comes from my god
[Music]
a fierce uncompromising show of American
individualism
[Music]
this morning we had 14 hundred and 25
people in attendance people came here
from 20 different states this morning to
worship with us reason being is people
have deep convictions about going to
church especially on Easter Sunday
Easter Sunday is the greatest Christian
holiday of the year because we celebrate
our resurrected Savior every churches
doors are shuttered in America as you
know worshiping God behind the screen on
a television is not the same as
worshiping God in person I say to them
don't be an hypocrite anybody that's on
that road right now anybody that's in a
retail store such as Walmart such as a
liquor store if you go to those places
but will not come to church your two
faiths
you're a hypocrite
it is hard to comprehend when you hear
stories like this one the Franklin's
lost four members of their family in
just 12 days every other bear was one of
the family members four family members
in the same ICU at the same time it was
first my uncle passed then a few days
later and my grandmother passed and a
few days later my dad passed and a few
days later after that other pass
you've dealt with so much loss in such a
short space of time how are you coping
the whole virus is just unbelievable and
what's the hardest for me some people
really think that it doesn't exist and
it's not real and we bear it for family
members buried my husband and to his
brothers in the same funeral three
caskets in a room and it I just want the
world to know that this is real
do you think the poverty to some extent
in New Orleans and Louisiana as well has
played a role people fearing they won't
have enough money to go to the doctors I
think health conditions has a huge part
of it in some cases but people in New
Orleans are very culturally
superstitious people don't like
hospitals here you have to be really
sick to go to our Hospital in New
Orleans forced him to go especially
african-american families we we and we
have big stigmas about hospitals local
author Maurice Ruffin sees a past and
present marked by disadvantage why do
you think Louisiana is suffering as much
as it is well I think they're part of
this economic disparity the South does
tend to have less money than the
northern part of the country here in
Louisiana in particular there's this
legacy of systemic racism that has been
born forth to the President and that
means a lot of african-americans in this
city in this state don't have good
economic opportunities to get education
or health care and those things have
played forward throughout this entire
pandemic
[Music]
the homeless in the city have lost their
shelters and soup kitchens some only
just lost their homes after losing their
jobs now they stand six feet apart
hoping to get food and that hunger that
insecurity is everywhere just look at
this San Diego and a seemingly endless
line of cars wait for a meal with more
than 22 million unemployed the
desperation Dwarfs anything in recent
history
[Music]
the food bank feeding America has seen a
40% increase in demand it expects a
shortfall of 1.4 billion dollars
[Music]
the government has tried to ease the
financial pain sending $1,200 checks to
Americans as part of an historic
stimulus package early evidence suggests
most of it is being spent on food there
will likely be a tale of two pandemics
in America that emerges in the next few
months one about those who were scared
disrupted but thanks to luck an
advantage they will survive physically
emotionally financially there are the
others though
who will be left with deep scars this
crisis will change the course of their
lives
[Music]
New Orleans is a city divided by the
haves and have-nots it is now being
stalked by a virus once again the
poorest people are carrying the heaviest
burden
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
unlike some countries America has no
experience of such a testing public
health emergency
in a cramped New York hospitals are so
full they're ferrying patients around in
groups in a vehicle normally used for
mass casualties
what is the most active days behind for
you now vomiting nausea vomiting okay
[Music]
[Music]
the United States has a global leader in
science technology and medicine but it
wasn't prepared for a pandemic no one
really was and it has never had to
collectively sacrifice quite like this
in just one week the world's superpower
was asking nurses to make their own
gowns and masks
[Music]
inside st. Joseph's Medical Center in
Yonkers are still processing it I always
trusted our government to be able to
provide the stuff we need I'm sorry you
know and then when you hear the
difference in the government and people
speaking for the government it doesn't
make sense
we need nursing staff we need physicians
we need PPE America is not Italy but you
know it turned out that we were much
worse so it's definitely something that
we like to think about and it's it's
hopefully going to change in the future
because this this is unnecessary and
just said at this point why do you think
America suffered so that we were
underpaid we were unprepared for this
the decisions made by state governors
have been critical some moving quickly
others not moving at all with some
high-stakes consequences
but there are those who still feel the
buck stops with the president I think he
needs to accept his responsibilities in
this and now try to fix it but don't
blame everybody else and all the other
people and the other governors and
mayors and things like that when it's
early intervention he I think he could
have prevented some of this you feel
that gone by yeah for sure
I mean it's a the administration I think
like it like I said just had no plan for
this so it's a it's hard when you are
going through this and you're in the
midst of it and there's really no
support coming from anywhere except you
know this local community are you having
chest pain yes yes okay so they want to
make sure everything in your lungs are
okay so this is a special kind of film
that we're ordering to look at it okay
what is clear inside some Josef's is the
inherent goodness of this country the
selflessness and the heroism of its
people however politically divided it
may be what are the things that stick in
your mind the most
I guess stories stories of a nurse
saying I had day off yesterday tears
just cut coming to my eyes and here
she's back again to work through the day
families being separated from their
dying loved ones I just
to me that's inconceivable know that
unfortunately there'll be a lot of
people who don't survive those at least
75% of the people who go on ventilators
are not coming off this team has seen
things they couldn't possibly coach
their hearts or minds for how much death
have you personally come from we've
never seen anything like this personally
and one 12-hour shift i pronounced six
people dead just me and that didn't
include the other physicians who had
deaths as well staggering number
staggering number I've never had
anything like that in my entire twenty
plus year career the psychological
impact on medical staff will likely be
felt and studied for years to come the
hardest moments are when you feel like
like you just stretched so thin where it
feels like there's no there's no way
that you could take care of the patients
that are here and the way that you're
trained to do so that's really the
hardest part because all of us here I
mean we went to school we learned all
the things you're supposed to do on a
regular basis and when the capacity is
overloaded and you just can't you can't
make those things happen it really it
weighs on you and you know
there are people that are that are going
through some serious hard times and
possibly their last moments on this
earth and you just want to be able to
stand there with them and hold their
hands and it's impossible this was new
to everyone dislocating but wildering
will reshape the country and many
families there are just so many stories
of loss and isolation I've just been
told they had a wife and husband a
sister and brother they came in together
they had to place them apart and they
all died alone
[Music]
and yet some states are already starting
to reopen
[Music]
the fact is America is a decentralized
country the champion's
individual liberties protests in Texas
Michigan and Minnesota show people are
impatient to get back to normal life
others want to keep the brakes on what
mr. Trump has had to wrestle with is
that choice is theirs to make when
somebody's the president of the United
States the authority is total and that's
so it's got to be what are you gonna
grant me what the Constitution gave me
before you were born it's called the
Tenth Amendment I didn't need the
President of the United States to tell
me that I'm governor I think that states
are much more weary of relying upon the
federal government now and they are they
formed the western states and the West
Coast in the Northeast have formed their
own consortiums that are going to make
decisions together about when to reopen
and I think that they're they've learned
a lesson about relying on leadership
from the White House and that they're
going to largely try to do this on their
own and it doesn't really matter almost
what Trump is going to say
[Music]
the United States was challenged by a
complex foe undaunted by its borders and
military might
it didn't mobilize a global response if
you expect that of anyone anymore
[Music]
no amount of money or power protects an
America like so many other nations it
was flat footed
what does seem distinct here though are
the extremes of the spread inequity and
politics
[Music]
lives have been ruptured but that trauma
has also brought a unity of purpose
[Music]
we've seen an abundance of courage
kindness and compassion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there was no single guiding light for
the world to follow
[Music]
drastic draconian action isn't easy in
any democracy this one won't ever be the
same again
you